welcome back to a20 special relativity
very early in this lecture we
discussed
what mars is and how we can understand a
mass of a proton and a mass of an
electron as it interacts
with the higgs background field
but here the question is slightly
different you want to understand
uh the difference or the lack of
difference between the mass
in a gravitational field compared to the
inertial mass a mass being pushed
through some force
and it's probably einstein's biggest
realization that those two things are
the same and and that finding is called
the equivalence principle the
equivalence of the gravitational and the
inertial mass
so if you are you know a freely falling
person um you will feel we will not feel
your own weight in your gravitational
field you will just drop
and the gravitational field provides an
acceleration and that acceleration if
you're standing in an elevator or just
sitting on this on a chair like i'm
doing right now
then sets up an accelerating reference
frame
so there's an equivalence between being
accelerated or being stationary in a
gravitational field
you